[Music]
welcome dear listeners to another
episode of Ana shabon
podcast so today we embark on a journey
through the interwinding paths of
College and Career
preparations a voice that for many is
riddled with anxiety
excitement hope and
trepidation but it's a journey worth
taking so you see in today's fast- faced
world the importance of preparation
cannot be
understanded whether it's applying for
colleges or launching into the
professional world the foundation stops
we take
set the
trajectory for the rest of our
lives let's dive deep into
this first consider
College it's way more than just a 4-year
experience or a place to take a
degree it's a
transformational period is where young
adults cultivate their identities
develop lifelong
friendships challenge their beliefs and
of course a cure
knowledge but the college PR
process that is where things can feel a
little bit
overwhelming I mean with a sea of
options how does one navigate
the key here is
researching a lot of
researching understand what you want
from a college
experience is it the
reputation the community or maybe the
courses or perhaps the
location by aligning your personal goals
with what a college offers you'll find a
place that feels
right now while colleg is is a fantastic
route for
many it's not the only path to a
successful
career vocational
training Apprentice
ships online courses and more have all
paved
ways for countless individuals to craft
meanful and prosperous
careers in today's digital age skills
are often valued as much as if not more
than
degrees the world is changing and it's
essential to recognize and adapt to
these
shifts and and this brings us to Career
preparations once the cap and grown are
stored
away the real world
beckons preparing for a career isn't
just about having a polished resume or
even acing the
interview though those are unly
crucial it's about understanding the
landscape of your chosen field
networking with
professionals and most importantly being
adapted the job market involves n rules
that exist today might be not longer
used for
tomorrow continuously learning and
upscaling have become not just
buzzwords but
Necessities to those that the cross
Crossroads of College and Career prep
here's my
advice embrace the
uncertainly while it's essential to
plan sometimes the unexpected turns in
life led to the most extraordinary
destinations invest in
yourself whether that means formal
education maybe soft skills or simply
broadening your
horizons but remember preparation isn't
just getting into a good college or
Landing that dream
job it's about equiping
yourself with the tools and mindset to
navigate the incate
tapestry of life's opportunities and
challenges in conclusion what whether
you're grinding up for college or
stepping into professional World know
that your journey is unique cherish it
learn from it and always remember the
best preparation for tomorrow is doing
your best
today and then no two Journeys are the
same take heart in knowing that every
decision every step contributes to your
story
stay curious stay
resilent and always be kind to yourself
on this adventure until the next time
keep forgiving your path and create your
legacy and lastly dear
listeners I want to leave you with one
more
thought your journey through College and
Career preparation is not just a means
it's an integral part of your life's
tapestry embrace the
challenges saver the
victories and most importantly stay true
to your dreams and
Ambitions as you navigate to the unique
course of your own life remember that
it's okay to deviate from the plan
sometimes for as often in those
unexpected de detours that you
discover the most extraordinary aspects
of
yourself keep your passion alive and may
your journey be filled with Endless
Possibilities until our next
episode keep forgiving your path and
create your
legacy and dear listeners as you embark
on this journey remember remember to
stay curious keep learning and embrace
the opportunities that come to your
way the road may have its ups and
downs but with determination and
preparation you'll pave a path to a
bright and fulfilling
future so this is it for today's episode
good luck
everyone and hopefully you enjoy enjoy
this episode as much as I did and take
[Music]
care